kräuter bist mein ganzes freut wie hast
du reagiert als beim burger battle
ausgeschieden bist serverseite skates
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video ich bin gerade aus dem urlaub
zurückgekommen bzw gestern zurück
gekommen und das ist das erste video war
es nicht mehr vor produziert ist das
nämlich sei völlig auf und ich habe auch
total gefragt was ihr euch denn mal so
wünschen würde weil nach zwei wochen
keine videos machen ist man ein bisschen
planung nun kreativ und da habe ich euch
einfach gedacht okay dann warum machen
wir nicht aus der not eine tugend und
fragen euch was sie so haben wollte
gesagt ich möchte gerne einen faq haben
meister ist glaube ich eine genau
und dann hab ich gestellt nämlich fakt
fragt unter dem hashtag fragen sie das
fragt fragen ich habe gefragt fragt
fragen alles klar
red fucking ausdruck okay gut jetzt
fragen gestellt so die damals
beantworten ok und bevor es losgeht
geht's los und zwar hier mit janina was
würdest du machen wenn du eine million
euro geschenkt bekommen bekommst
bekommst also nicht bekommen bekommst
ich sagte komm wieder noch einen würden
hinten dranhängen aber nein bekommst
eine million euro
ich würde mir eine in kluges investment
überlegen für 700.000 euro würde
vielleicht vielleicht will ich auch
meiner mutter hinaus kaufen
doch oder zumindest meine wohnung ja
doch wirklich machen dann sagt man
investiert 500.000 dann würde ich meiner
mutter eine wohnung kaufen für 300.000
und die restlichen von der rest ohne
tausend vielleicht mal hunderttausend
spenden und die restlichen
hunderttausend verleben
für was man eben so macht aber nicht in
ein auto investieren oder so sondern
keine ahnung hessen gehen und so paar
jahre lang ihr wisst schon was ich meine
okay nun abend auf fische fragt kann man
den essens bürger trotzdem auch bei max
essen wenn er nicht auf dem neuesten
stand
nee das geht nicht warum kommt schon
dieses diese parole dass es falsch wäre
verriet nein das macht keinen sinn
aber okay ich will nicht zugesagt haben
kann man leider nicht mehr den gab es
nur bis zum zwölften achten nur während
das voting lief
und jetzt gibt es nicht mehr und bürger
battle ist vorbei und ich mal
rausgeflogen
ja vielleicht kommt dazu auch eine frage
aber dann kann ich dazu noch was
erzählen aber ja was okay leute ich
dachte das irgendwie dahinter gut okay
gut der parcours ist keine unmöglich
aber hey hier den akku kann ich zum
beispiel noch gar nicht zwingen muss ich
gerade ein bisschen logo es langgeht
hallo
ja vielleicht doch nicht hier lang
aha ich glaube hier lange ja sehr gut
die nächste frage wann bekommst du
deinen eigenen mercat soviel götze 0 1
also die designs stehen dafür wann ich
die t shirts tatsächlich rausbringe ist
eine andere frage weil keine ahnung sie
liebt mich jetzt nicht so einen finger
jetzt unbedingt so schnell wie möglich
merge rauszubringen alter schwede jetzt
bitte nicht unter von hier sagt nein den
spruch nicht den körper nicht schaffen
herr wie denn hier runter doch den kann
man kann man sogar easy schaffen sie
nicht aber den kann man schaffen glaube
da kann man schaffen leute sagen hat so
richtig komisch aus ja ist nun ist die
designs stehen vielleicht bringe ich
nämlich das haus vielleicht am main just
do it oder am maifest fall runter hier
nein egal ist was ich zumindest den weg
gebracht weiter im text das hat das ist
man überhaupt nicht will so einen
ekligen parcours die man nicht kennt man
eigentlich erst mal dass worte gar noch
fragen beantworten will
ok
irgendwas in meinem kopf wie ist das
wetter so in deutschland fragt janina
etwa anfrage von der in italien im
urlaub
das freut mich für dich janina das
wetter hier in deutschland ist zumindest
bei mir bist du ein bisschen grauen
himmels bisschen grau bis hinzugezogen
ähnlich wie immigranten zack-zack ja das
passt eine speise ist aber immer noch
warm also alles easy bmg emi der junge
ich wäre fast schon wieder zu weit
gesprungen wäre okay wissen schon beim
modul 7
das fürchtet herrchen leuten um mich
immer das freiburger okay wie findest du
die kommunikation herrscht der community
sagt danke fragt news es kay die fand
ich echt cool eigentlich ich weiß nicht
von wem wie kam aber das war das erste
was ich gesehen habe als ich aus dem
urlaub zurückkam und mal wieder heimisch
in twitter eingeloggt habe sah ich
dieses komische sagt danke das fand ich
eigentlich mega mega net eine coole
aktion community sagt danke 2 war das
glaube ich so gerne wieder welche
youtuber ist dein lieblings youtube
feiert pixel button
ich schaue eigentlich momentan am
liebsten videos von casey also casey
leistet ist es nicht besonders originell
ist das machen 300.000 leute auch an
jeden tag aber das eis des youtuber ganz
cool wenn man sich gerade irgendwie
unmotiviert fühlt bisschen schlapp fühlt
dann kommen immer casey zu schauen und
sagt dann irgendwas tolles oder so oder
macht irgendwas dann denkt man sich aber
das kann ich auch dann hat man wieder
ein bisschen mehr power in diesem sinne
sei allein seine videos eigentlich nicht
nur eine gute sache wer hilft der welt
wisst ihr wie ich meine wer hilft dem
laden dass der hofft dass der nicht nach
unten chips und cola oder kekse mit
milch so wie ich drauf bin würde ich
wahrscheinlich chips mit milch trinken
oder keine ahnung kekse mit cola oder
kekse chips wahrscheinlich eher kekse
chips
das ist ziemlich meine art habe ich die
kiste ehrlich ist da habe ich mag es
einfach so sehr herzhaftes und süßes zu
kombinieren und zu jeder tageszeit
also es kann vorkommen dass ich mal
irgendwie ins wäldchen streusel und eine
ein bienenstich zusammen mit
forellenfilets frühstücke das kann max
bezeugen
ja ich habe ein bisschen komisch
essgewohnheiten oder ich brauche einfach
an ihre meister etwas bisschen was
höchstwahrscheinlich habe ich daher
wieder
und weil sie so noch nicht da ist
aber hey okay es expertin fragt hast du
bestimmt die planung zu minecraft
projekten
ja ich hab ein projekt was ich alleine
machen wie geplant dann gibt es ein
projekt geplant zusammen mit den laden
also mit luca und max und noch ein
projekt mit max was demnächst gedreht
wird
und noch eine andere sache das ist sagte
michael projekt aber das kommt auch auf
youtube das kann ich nicht sprechen und
zwar werde ich werde ich am 21 mit einem
sehr guten freund von mir durch europa
fahren mit dem auto
das haben wir schon mal gemacht für alle
denen barcelona block noch kennen da
sind einer person angefahren über nacht
das machen wir ein bisschen länger so
gar keine zehn tage
das geht am 21 sie werden erst ein
bisschen nach berlin fahren und dann von
berlin vielleicht nach dänemark schweden
oder runter nach malaga keine ahnung es
wird sich zeigen
es wird auf jeden fall richtig cool ich
sehe zu dass ich eine videokamera dann
bekomme meine läge ja ist ja putsch
gegangen bzw habe ich vergessen weil ich
zur vorspiel zu einer übereilten abreise
genötigt wurde aber alles gut die zeit
weg und da gucke ich dass eine kamera
bekommen hat kann man das auch bloggen
und da haben dafür habe ich auch eine
gute idee übrigens keine formale idee so
fragen sie das kommt heute in stream
ich hatte eigentlich schon mal wieder
wissen zu streamen muss ja gucken ich
hänge auch momentan mit einem anderen
projekt ziemlich hinterher weil ich für
das im urlaub nichts gemacht habe
das ist eigentlich momentan wichtiger
als streamen und noch wichtig ist dass
ich dann ins ziel komme die western hier
mit nice auch noch ins goal gekommen
das coverage gekommen
wie ein us amerikanischer rapper so geh
mal kurz weg eine sache wie ich gerne in
chanten zwar ich würde sagen ja mein
schwert ehrlich gesagt dass mein tier
schreibt die comcom höre ich auf euch
nicht in stand schon mal schwer okay
schauen wir nicht games hessen kann hier
sich entscheiden ok ich kann aber nicht
entstanden obwohl ich ein level up on
judgement bank existiert immer noch eine
1.807 mac abfragt urlaubs fazit cool
aber dass abreisen war ungewohnt
also wir fahren ja immer wieder dahin wo
wir da war sogar recht häufig und
dadurch hat man halt schon so ein
gewisses urlaubskonzept weiß wie es das
anfühlt wenn man halt ankommt wenn man
ein pferd aber dass man halt
zwischendurch mal weg fährt das ist voll
ungewohnt deswegen keine ahnung das war
ganz so also seltsamsten ein bisschen
komisch aber dafür war halt köln also
als urlaub vom urlaub auch sehr gut hat
bisschen abwechslung gebracht
das fand ich gut so harriet tatsächlich
schon wieder ein bisschen hoch ist mein
ganzer und gefreut wie hast du reagiert
als beim burger battle ausgeschieden
bist ps wird es den gewinn erding
gewinnen verdient gewinn verdient den
sieg verdient oder catering gewinnen ja
ich hab mich ziemlich aufgeregt weil es
auch bis in meiner eigenen dummheit
geschuldet ist weil ich mich da zu sehr
in sicherheit gewogen habe hätte
vielleicht auch wenn der gegner noch
keine watts generiert hat noch bisschen
mehr pushen sollen mehr machen sollen
aber okay zu dem zeitpunkt sei es nicht
danach aus als wäre es nötig und dann am
ende war es nötig dann lagen auf einmal
hinten und ich hab's nicht so ganz ernst
genommen bleibt okay das können auch
letzten minute noch drehen
dann haben wir es mit leider nicht
geschaffen sind 49 52 aus geschehen so
lächerlich was du wie dieser typ der die
ganze zeit wegrennt komplexer jungen eis
jetzt möchte ich auch warum hat er noch
ein leben was hast du hier für mich eine
tolle day damit den doctor away geben
kann ist dass dafür gedacht oder
denn eisen schwert übrigens das texture
pack was wir hier grad spielen ist ein
512 er 3d kraft weil ich das wahre
texture pack irgendwie nicht mehr sehen
konnte das war mal zwar ganz witzig so
ein nötiges zu spielen aber ja roma auf
dauer dann auch nicht so was geht bei
euch bei den kämpfen gegeneinander oder
macht es nicht wie ist die lage vor ort
combo alter junge der combo kommen jetzt
wieder auf den kern und e-business beim
renault sehr schöner dass ich bisschen
verlaufen sowie hänsel und gretel die
alten ruhen
das ist natürlich ein lokal stil
ja oh bitte box einfach gegenseitig ohne
witz so jetzt kann ich doch mal rein
hawass juli was hat er noch stress
gemacht wo ich würde sagen schon sagen
es regel leiter des direkt hinter der
fokus lag hamm lag die und tnt geplanten
einfach das tnt nicht gibt er ist okay
gerade okay selbstgemacht ständig sogar
richtig live egal heute ist ja ok und
ich spielte auf einer skala von null bis
müsse wie armselig ist der gewinner des
bürgergeldes für dich faktor mac auf die
falle gehe ich jetzt mal nicht ein
ich hab mich halt ich habe mich über
mich selbst hat mich hat vor allem
aufgeregt wisst ihr was ich habe einfach
so viele fälle wie setze ich die nicht
ein
zudem war der gegner hinter mir aber joh
13 viele junge das ist krass fiel aber
ist ein bisschen al ko spielen das thema
klatschen ja einfach da war so keine
chance muss man nicht kommen wo der club
mit okay noch feierlich nach den kompass
mit nice verpflegt
so gut das essen was willst du wenn die
reise gewinns in amerika unbedingt sehen
einfach nur marie marie ist um mir zu
sagen dass ich schon seit vier tagen
ausgeschieden bin dass der bürger battle
und die reise in die usa
leider nicht mehr gewinnen kann dann
gibt's den nächsten stream
ich würde sagen bis zum 21 auf jeden
fall nochmal stream
doch schon will ich sage ich okay wird
hat gepasst kann man einfach blocken als
ob seiner angel von da drüben durch die
wand suchen alles klar minecraft er
konnte seite ich bin natürlich robert
ist es ist richtig das ist der trick
wenn man nebenbei auf einem monitor
fragen lesen muss ja komm gib mir heraus
ich habe ich habe auch noch etwas für
dich wenn du her kommen wird ist so ich
habe leider gerade eben schon meine
aufgabe gehabt aber irgendeine mein ton
kaputt weil weiligmann eine kleine
festplatte voll gemeldet habe und
otterstedt nimmt auf die auf und dann
war die aufnahme weg und ich hab mich ab
richtig gewartet weil das eigentlich
echt gut war
bitte dann legt doch nicht so bitte leg
nicht so dein leben weg von meinem spiel
warte so fazit zu dem video days
überraschend viele autogramme autogramme
gegeben um die party ist ein bisschen
lärm aber war fall sehr sehr cool ganz
locker zu treffen vor allem felix
patrick usw
jonas die ganzen menschen die man
getroffen hat auch schon witzig jetzt
zieht sich das so ewig auch bitte wenn
nicht weg
sag ich mit dreieinhalb herzens ist
schon ein bisschen dumm so hashtag frage
sagt ist ein projekt in planung habe ich
schon beantwortet am montag ich habe den
fehler habe ich noch in rheinsberg stehe
hier sieht man doch oder nicht erlebt
hat das feld richtig ab okay der war
locker gab folge erlebt hat so dass
netto jungen ein elektrisches okay geht
dornige down 22 sekunden auch hier
drüben ist er der checkpoint okay wir
sind beim unfall habe ich noch nicht so
easy 654 wo ist der kommt nicht mehr
oder
der kommt nicht die gewonnen einfach
zeitlos